[تصفيق]
عندما أسافر إلى مناطق الحرب
وأغادر
منزلي
دائمًا ، أقوم دائمًا بتذكرة
ذهاب فقط يستعد الدكتور مانزيير يازجي
لرحلة قام بها قبل
رحلته الثالثة من منزله في إدينبورغ بولاية
تكساس إلى شرق أوكرانيا كطبيب
أولاً
من واجبنا وأخلاقنا مساعدة
كل شخص بحاجة إليه في العالم ، وأنا
أفهم هذا الشعور بأنني كنت في
مناطق الحرب ومناطق الكوارث كمراسل
منذر ، وكنت في هايتي في نفس
الوقت في عام 2010
في بعض الأوقات التي شعرت فيها بأنني مضطر  للمساعدة في
مدى قلقك الآن بشأن سلامتك الخاصة في
كل مرة أعود فيها ، أقول إن
هذه ربما تكون المرة الأخيرة التي سأذهب فيها
عندما أقرر المجيء ، إنه خوف كبير
وفي غضون دقيقة أتذكر
وعدي و  لماذا فقد الناس
حياتهم وأرى أطفالهم لا يراهم ،
هل نحن نعمل بشكل مختلف؟
وضع نفسه في وضع مماثل
في بلد آخر ،
ما يحدث هو أوكرانيا ،
لقد حدث في سوريا
وأشعر
أنني جزء منهم
منذ ما يقرب من شهرين من الحرب ، وما لا يقل عن
119 هجومًا على العيادات والمستشفيات
تركت النظام الصحي الأوكراني في
حالة من الفوضى
و  في حاجة ماسة إلى المساعدة الخارجية
، المستشفيات
التي
هاجمها الجيش الروسي
، يقضي طبيب للطبيب الدكتور يازجي
الأيام الخمسة التالية في حالة ضبابية مستمرة تقريبًا ،
وأتساءل عما إذا كان
بإمكانك وصف ما تواجهه ،
أليس كذلك؟  عناية كافية لإعطاء
الكثير من
الصدمات في العمليات الجراحية عالية التواطؤ مثل ما
أجرينا الجراحة آه ويوم واحد
مثل شخص فقد نصف
الكتف العلوي الخلفي العلوي ، الجزء العلوي من
الذراع ، الصدر ، الجزء العلوي من الصدر ، نجا هذا الرجل ،
هناك مشاكل في الماء و
الكهرباء ، هناك نقص في
الإمدادات الطبية
تؤدي ما يصل إلى ستة
عمليات في اليوم ، ما يفعله الدكتور ياجي
وزملاؤه الأوكرانيون
هو في الخداع  نص من الأشياء التي لا
تقل عن معجزة
شيء واحد تعلمه في سوريا هو
الحاجة إلى إجراء ترقيع للجلد في أقرب وقت
ممكن لتقليل خطر الإصابة ،
وهذا هو أصعب
نوع من الجراحة لأنه
كلما غطيت العظم أسرع.  تسهيل
الشفاء ومنع العدوى ،
هؤلاء هم المرضى الذين أصيبوا
في هذه الانفجارات
التي شهدناها على شاشات التلفزيون ،
فقد تسببوا في ترهل الجلد ، وربما أصيبوا بكسر في العظام
، وقد يحتاجون إلى بتر ، لذا فأنت
تتحدث عن صنع اللوحات لتجربتها و
لمحاولة الاعتناء بهم هو أن هذا
صحيح حقًا يوفر البتر لدينا ، فأنت
تصنع فرقًا كبيرًا في حياة الناس ،
لا يقدم الدكتور يازجي الدعم الطبي فقط على
الرغم من أنه يوفر شكلاً من أشكال
التغذية العقلية للأطباء الأوكرانيين
أيضًا عندما أرى الأوكرانية.
طبيب يعاني
لأنك تعلم أنه مرهق
جسديًا
والهجوم عليه ، أرى أن صورتنا الشخصية
كانت هناك
بهذه الطريقة وهذا كله يجعلني
أذهب إلى المملكة المتحدة  وكون
معهم في الصباح التالي لمكالمتنا ، بدأ
في العودة إلى المنزل
لكنه
غادر بوعده بالعودة